if a patient comes in and they tell me
they fell and I write that in the chart
patient fell while they fell at work
their health insurance might deny that
claim and say what do you mean they fell
at work you said in your note that means
workers compensation has to cover it not
us the same thing will happen with a car
accident a patient will come to see me
they'll say my back hurts but in the
note they'll say oh I had a car accident
four years ago the insurance will deny
it and say the auto insurance is
supposed to pay for this so they all had
kicked the bucket on who's supposed to
make the payment like you cannot imagine
a more broken system and the fact that
it's still somehow works is magical